san mateo mentioned he really wanted to
have this process and particularly this
time of year
be collaborative what has that been like
so far
and what are some progress points
that you can see tangibly happening in
that regard
yeah i mean i think it's been a great
process so far obviously we're a little
bit limited at certain points during the
offseason and our ability to communicate
when it comes to football and all that
but you know i think he understands that
i've been
you know in four different offenses with
a bunch of different coordinators and
seen a lot of different football and and
you know he's been around a while too so
uh it's been nice being able to talk
ball
um you know and it can be the simplest
things if an individual route on a play
or it's a full play concept or it's a
half field read or whatever it is
there's things that i've done in the
past that i think you know make sense to
him and and make sense for our offense
there's also things that
you know i've never been exposed to that
are in this offense that i'm trying to
learn and make
second nature to myself as well so um
it's been fun we've been able to kind of
bounce ideas back and forth off of each
other
um you know and uh you know we'll figure
out what this thing looks like
you know come august september
you know if we'd have seen that clip two
years ago
we'd have lost our minds first of all
that was before the rams completely
did whatever they did to their uniform
and their logo and their look we would
have been
we would have thought we were on a
different planet and to see matthew
stafford in that setting
it's just incomprehensible but that's
where we are
stafford with the new look rams like it
or not
not for me and uh we may like the result
because he's definitely an upgrade over
jared
goff that's what the defensive lineman
said i think it was brockers
it was michael brocker who ended up
getting traded
to the lion guard all that stuff
i said not just you're trying to be a
good teammate
sometimes you say things like that by
the way you're a great quarterback
yeah seriously well i mean listen we
know it's an upgrade everybody in
football knows it's an upgrade
i'm rooting for the the rams in in a way
really because
yeah i want to see the the haters of the
matthew stafford universe you know
be put into place a little bit because
again i think you and i have discussed
this a lot since we've known each other
he's really talented he's a lot better
than what people think
you know and he's been stuck stuck up
there in crapola for
for a long time so now he's got some
some
players and some coaches around him and
that's let's see what they can do but
they have not had a quarterback like
this that's got
this type of arm this type of explosive
uh just mindset as far as dropping back
to pass
and looking to torch you and then you
talk mcvay's genius off of that and all
of those type of things
i mean it could be a special combination
i'm expecting it to be really damn good
and a lot of fun to watch
especially because they got some studs
and some stars around him too so that's
going to make things fun to watch too
i recall that when you did your first
top
40 list when we were together stafford
was number three
he was up there now he's fallen since
then but you had him at number three
so what kind of guy like mcvay yeah
who's been working with jared goff the
entire time he's been a head coach what
can he learn
from a guy like matthew stafford who's
been around
uh you know 12 years now in the nfl yeah
well you know again i think mcveigh's
awesome
in the fact that he's a listener that's
why he's a great coach
he listens he communicates i bet you
stafford's going to be able to bring
some
some passing drop back concepts to the
offense
and he's going to teach sean mcveigh how
he read it and things like that
and mcfae's going to go i like that i
can get behind that i've never really
learned it that way or done that play i
always wondered how
that was coached exactly so i do think
there's going to be elements to where
he'll bring to the offense that
we haven't seen the rams do with jared
goff because matt stafford's just gonna
go hey look this has worked really well
for me
for five ten years whatever a little bit
like we saw brady do some of that with
tampa bay
and then of course the the real exciting
part is the opposite side of that
the play actions the boots and how great
mcveigh is at doing that and the uptempo
offense
but then he's got a great feel of
dialing up big plays from time to time
and now he's just got
a blank canvas just to draw people going
everywhere and just
hey this guy can fade this way and throw
it that way and do
do anything he can do anything on the
football field it's one of the greatest
arms
in the history of the sport so that's
where it's going to be fun
yeah and uh look i i think the general
consensus is the rams have the chance to
be
nothing against jared goff but
dramatically better with matthew
stafford and this is going to be
a great litmus test both as it relates
to the lions
and it relates to the rams and the two
quarterbacks
will the rams be dramatically better
with stafford let's look at
the help that matthew stafford has
around him he hasn't had much help
historically in his career although
there was a time he had in dominican
sioux and he had calvin johnson
and uh they still didn't do all that
much no running back
malcolm brown's out cam akers and daryl
henderson are there
acres a rookie last year emerged as the
guy and sean mcvay has said things
suggesting that he can be
the every down i think they're done with
the the
three-headed monster and i think they're
ready to try to get back to having a
todd gurley type of a presence and
they're gonna give acres every chance to
be that guy chris yeah i think so too
well when you have a stud and acres i
think is on the edge of being like a
real real stud
you know you do them a disservice at
times by doing running back by committee
because really they're better as they
play and they get in the flow of the
game and get a feel for the cutback
lanes
and things like that so they got a guy
that i think is a borderline
superstar type talent at tailback and i
think mcveigh probably recognizes that
and goes you know what
we're going to give him his touches i'm
not going to like waste a play where it
could have been an 80 yard touchdown
just because i'm going to go the
committee approach but dan those are two
good running backs henderson's real damn
good too
fits what they want to do inside outside
zone
good good pass catchers out of the
backfield that's a pretty strong one-two
tandem there but you know you said it
acres is
acres is the real deal and then at the
receiver position cooper cup and robert
woods are the holdovers
they really didn't have a replacement
for brandon cooks
last year now they have desean jackson
if he can stay healthy great
the question is can he stay healthy and
then they have the the the
young version of desean jackson and due
to outwell who they drafted with their
first pick this year even though their
first pick came late in the draft
because they
keep trading their first rounders van
jefferson also on the roster
what do you make of the rams receiving
core right now
real strong i mean i think it's a real
strong group right there
you got a little bit of everything first
off cup and woods
are not superstar receivers they're not
maybe top
ten receivers in football but they both
might be
somewhere between 10 and 20 and can do
everything
like can beat you deep can run the
julian edelman underneath routes
make plays after the catch get yards
that way you know they're tough
they block like that's where the beauty
is of those two receivers cup and woods
are interchangeable and you can't pin
either one to like a certain role and
to me that makes you know certain
offenses really good but now you add the
desean jackson tutu out well
aspect of it wow i mean two two atwell's
got three rockets up his butt just like
desean jackson used to have
i'm gonna say he's got two and a half
now at his older age but either way
that's gonna add another dynamic too
and fits really well with
your quarterback who can launch it as
good as anybody we've seen in football
history
so that's where they're gonna be able to
put you in a bind you know think about
it this way it's
you know they could have desean jackson
here in a tight split and robert woods
here
and 2-2 atwell the the guy with three
rockets up his butt he could be that
fake speed sweep guy so now you're
giving him the ball and you're worried
about going sideline to sideline and
there's cam acres
oh wait stafford kept the ball off of
play action
and now desean jackson we were so
worried sideline to sideline he's flying
down the middle for an 80 yard touchdown
that's where i think the beauty of their
little wide receiver unit can really be
in mcvay's formula
yeah and i think this is the kind of
thing that can maybe
reinvigorate mcvay maybe things were
getting a little stale
i know they made it to the final eight
last year right they beat the seahawks
in a playoff game in seattle which in
and of itself is impressive
but there's just been kind of this sense
that the rams have been in a funk ever
since
they lost in the super bowl to the
patriots not that that's an uncommon
reality i think a lot of teams that get
to the super bowl and lose to the
patriots have
you know struggles getting over it
especially when it felt like a game that
the rams could have won
this is kind of the reset that i think
sean mcvay needed you know
you get some speed back in the receiving
core
you replace your quarterback with a guy
that you think can get it done
and this would be one of the all-time
fascinating stories
in in recent nfl history if a guy who
was mired in crapola
as you said right the detroit alliance
could go to la and all of a sudden have
this second act rich gannon recently
told i think sam farmer the la times
that he sees this like a ganon and john
gruden
pairing leighton gannon's career not
that ganon was ever matthew stafford
before
but gannon became an mvp once he hooked
up with john gruden yeah i
i i'm excited like that i saw rich say
that i mean it was a
a great compliment and yeah i mean look
what it did for rich cannon to get with
a
you know boy genius you know that's what
gruden was at that time and
we know that's what we talk about
mcveigh that way mike i think you're
you're spot on there
though i think kind of that new blood
and the new quarterback
is gonna like you know get the juices
flowing for mcvay
oh wait i could do this and i can do
that and oh wait desean jackson i
haven't had a guy that can really run
and take the top off of defense like
that in a long time
you know i the rams that they listen
they're like hollywood they're they're
they're star-studded
they're star-studded you know but like
hollywood
people they can be a little shallow at
times and that's where their team is too
and i'm saying that jokingly you know
that's kind of
like but yeah that that's the only thing
i worry about with the rams and their
team as we go through here
it it's it's a very top-ended roster
that's the only thing i worry about with
the rams a few injuries
and i think it could really change their
football team we know they've made all
these demands for stars and trades and
traded draft picks and everything like
that
and because of that yeah a lot of their
salary cap is tied up into just a few
guys
there's not a lot of depth on this
football team and i think that's the
scariest aspect for them
and here's the other reality you know in
la the b side to the record
or the second movie on the double
feature at the drive-in there's a chance
it's going to be better
than the main attraction they got to
worry about the charters
not in the same conference they only
play once every four years in games that
count
but the chargers are on the rise and if
the rams don't get better
they're going to have to be very
concerned about being second fiddle in
their own stadium offensive line yeah
andrew whitworth david edwards brian
allen austin corbett rob
havenstein side to side you know
whitworth just keeps going
at some point they got to have a
post-whitworth plan but he keeps going
where is that offensive line and they
got to keep
stafford health i know middle of the
road probably even below like
a little bit of the middle of the pack
in my opinion you know the rams have
taken the approach of like
we're going to get stars at the other
position and i think they go mcvay and
his offense and his coaching
they'll protect and make our average to
below average offensive line
look a little better than they actually
are they've kind of taken that angle
that's what they are
they haven't spend great money or
resources on offensive line play because
i think
mcveigh looks at it and goes wait i know
how to coach the run game
i can keep people off my stuff with the
fake speed sweeps and all the
misdirection we do
so i don't want to pay offensive linemen
you know 15 million and 20 million
dollars a year
that's the approach they've taken they
kind of do it with their system
and mcveigh's coaching it's a solid
group but
in my eyes certainly not a special group
by any stretch of the imagination
yeah and that's really the concern hey
we spend seven months
talking about possibilities and the
glasses are all half full then you start
playing and
injuries impact a team and one way to
get a quarterback injured is to have a
crappy offensive line
one way to get a quarterback injured is
to have aaron donald chasing the
quarterback around
he's still the greatest in the game what
do we think of the front seven though
now with donald leonard floyd ashawn
robinson still there sebastian joseph
day
and others where is that is it just the
presence of aaron donald makes it great
regardless of who else is there well
it definitely brings it to another level
you're right about that i mean he's you
know
you you had that article on pft this
week he's the best corner in football
because he put so much pressure on the
quarterback right
i mean he's he's he's a first-half
ballot hall of famer
we're looking at lt reggie white you
name ray lewis this is aaron donald he's
one of the greatest defensive players in
the history of football
there's no let's just all take it and
enjoy it that's the he is
one of the greatest of all time that's
what he is
and yeah he is the jump off point d line
i think is pretty damn good i mean
leonard floyd you know me i got a man
crush on him
i think he's awesome on the edge a sean
robinson can be a beast in the middle
they gotta find that other guy that
comes off the edge i don't know if
that's last year's fourth round pick
terrell lewis
who i loved out of alabama he's kind of
a first round talent mike that had like
a knee issue
maybe he comes in and adds to the pass
rush that's where they gonna have to
figure this out
it's gonna be interesting too you know
raheem morse there as the d coordinator
right
so it's a definitely a different scheme
than brandon staley
and now they're gonna be running a
little bit more seattle scheme
which you know it's funny the nfc west
has got three teams running the same
defensive system basically
i am kind of like just excited to see
how that plays out
but the defense is star-studded but just
like we kind of talked about
man one or two injuries would scare the
hell out of me
it's young and i'm proven in some other
areas and that's where
we'll see if they can dodge the bullet
that way a lot of eggs in a couple of
baskets yeah between donald
on the front seven and jaylen ramsey in
the secondary they used that first round
restricted free agency tender to keep
darius williams around they didn't need
to they could have gone with the second
rounder but it shows they like him
they believe in him yeah they may not be
able to pay him next year because of
ramsey a guy they gave up two
first-round picks for look they've been
a team
not bashful giving up first round picks
to get established veterans
but if those veterans get hurt where's
your depth i think that's
a concern both sides of the ball really
for the rams but especially on defense
especially on defense yeah i mean you
said you take
leonard floyd aaron donald and jaylen
ramsey i mean holy crap
that's that's a lot of damn money for
three guys yeah the rest of the team is
yeah younger guys you know guys who are
still trying to prove that they're
worthy of you know making a big money
second type contract that type of stuff
they've done a great job of filling in
those kind of areas with guys that are
under the radar or late round trap picks
that's really where they've saved their
football team that way
um but yeah they're living dangerously
like you said it's it's one or two
injuries and all of a sudden you could
go this is the best defensive football
and now they're like the 20th best
because those two guys are gone
and you know the rams are in one of the
toughest divisions in football
cardinals seahawks 49ers all have reason
to be optimistic about this season
um but i you know there are going to be
people who when it's time to make those
preseason picks they're going to look at
the rams they're going to look where
they are
look what we see in the preseason not
that we see a lot of the playbook
but you just once you get comfortable
you get comfortable with matthew
stafford in that funky
helmet that the rams now wear you're
going to have some people warming up to
the idea of the rams
becoming the second team
in consecutive years after 54 super
bowls with no one
playing in the super bowl in their home
stadium we could go two for two
with the buccaneers last year in the
rams this year wouldn't shock me
it really wouldn't i mean we know what
they're capable of
i still think their defense no matter
what would the coaching change
is going to be a top five defense as
long as they stay healthy
you know yeah they lost staley but
raheem morris is really damn good too
and creative he'll leave the boundaries
of the seattle scheme
and then you know we hit on the offense
we know there's talent
but now you got another schematical
advantage there with stafford and
a new look that you know defenses in the
nfc west are going to be like i'm not
sure exactly how they're going to
attack us with stafford so they might be
able to catch some people off guard
early in the year too
uh wouldn't be shocking i mean their
offense is going to improve it's going
to go from wherever it was last year to
top tennis this year uh i i that that's
how i feel about it at least
i you know i have there's an intriguing
wrinkle here as well
because my next question for you is
which team
in the division poses the greatest
threat
to the rams but you mentioned raheem
morris a couple of times his recent
history
has been intriguing he's worked
hand-in-hand
with kyle shanahan in atlanta he's just
back on defense recently he was
the passing game coordinator in 2015 and
2016 with kyle
the uh the um
receivers coach in 2016 with kyle that
was the year they almost
won the super bowl they were up 28 to
three there's
there's some intermingling of secrets
there oh definitely they might come to a
boil when those teams play each other
twice this year i'm glad you brought it
up mike
a hundred percent i would think it's
part of the reason
mcveigh brought him out there let's not
forget mcveigh and raheem morris were
also with shanahan in washington
so there is gonna be knowledge of oh
i remember kyle likes to do this on this
run play or if we play
this defense they they block it this way
in the run game and do those things it
is going to be an advantage
for the rams and morris the fact that
he's there and has direct knowledge of
the shanahan offense so
you're right it adds to that dynamic you
know that's why i picked that mcvey
shanahan that's the playoff matchup i
would like there because there's a lot
of personal stuff there it's really
awesome in the nfc west
i mean between those two teams the
cardinals got better
seattle we know is going to be in the
mix i mean damn is that some division i
have a hard time i i
last week i was going to afc north the
best division and now we're talking
about the nfc west right now i'm going
no i think the nfc west is still the
best i mean it's phenomenal
it's amazing that raheem morris hasn't
gotten more serious consideration to be
a coach again he was too young when he
got his first job i don't think he was
ready to be thrust into that rory
tampa at age 32. he's had very diverse
experience since then on both sides of
the ball
how many times do you see a coach that's
been
a high level offensive coach high level
defensive coach
somebody's going to end up with a hell
of a head coach eventually raheem morris
who is only 44 years old chris
yeah he's going to get a second action
somewhere and i got a feeling he's going
to be pretty damn good i agree
you mean too young maybe i was real
close to raheem when i was in tampa
i mean too young but always knew he was
gonna be a rising star and
i i'll say this too the bucks did
nothing to really help him when he took
over for john gruden
they spent no money you know that's the
one thing i'll always remember is
he got there he coached the team they
did nothing greg ciano took over and
they spent like 400 million dollars that
off season
you know not you know i'm joking of
course but yes
he's got a mike tomlin type of
leadership attitude communication style
and i'm with you if you made me bet
money i think
raheem morris was great as a head coach
last year for the falcons and what he
did there
i think the second time around is going
to work and uh will be a lot more
successful than what he had in tampa
everything about the way that his
arrival in tampa went down had bad karma
written all over it they throw out
gruden and bruce allen
they give the jobs to raheem morris and
mark dominic
and it was clear that it was set up
ahead of time a palace coup type of a
thing it just
it was just it was bad from the get-go
and uh
i think second time around and he was
yeah look you're young and you're
ambitious you're not going to say no hey
you want to be the head coach what do
you say no
right no right i'm loyal to the guy that
you're firing no i don't want to take
over
um but but i think 12 years later with
all the experience he's had since then
and what he's going to get this year
with mcvay this guy's going to be ready
when january rolls around and somebody's
going to get a pretty good head coach